let's go next to our caller from the 847
area code who's calling today from 847.
hey david it's uh eli gray i'm a proud
new member
and uh i'm so happy to be talking you
love the show thank you eli i appreciate
that
so a couple things that i want to
actually help answer for your last
caller
okay um the public my kids are 13 and 11
and the school system just sent out
something saying we have the option to
keep them home
there may be only certain days they go
to school or there may be an e-learning
only
option so i don't even know that they're
necessarily going to open the public
school
what what state what state is this in
eli where are you located
i'm in the chicago suburbs okay got it
got it yeah i mean listen i think that
th this is much like with the shutdowns
which is
donald trump likes to pretend that he's
the boss and he tells the 50 states what
to do but these are decisions that are
probably going to vary dramatically
between states and even within states i
imagine that there will be parts of
states and school districts that say
we're going to do this or we're going to
do that
the idea that trump is going to be
running the decisions for all of these
school districts is a fantasy
yeah it's pretty much i think governor
pritzker here is doing a wonderful job
and that's why they monitor it so
in case they need to pull back they're
not going to put anyone at risk
especially like my family we all have as
well unfortunately
yeah um and then the other thing i was
going to say about the kanye thing is
he's calling forbes magazine
and elon musk is kind of pushing him
here he's trying to call his party the
birthday parties
and claiming if you get a vaccine for
coronavirus
it's the mark of the beast so i don't
think he's going to be getting anybody
to vote for him
yeah no kanye kanye's comments about
vaccines were crazy
but but to get back to something that's
much more relevant though than kanye
so if what is you have you decided your
kids aren't going into school
or what what are you going to wait to
see what the school district decides
i have a feeling what's going to end up
coming down with the district is
you know they're very aware of children
with allergies or autoimmune diseases
that it's going to come down to they're
going to do a risk assessment from the
top down
and recommend to parents or maybe
mandate it saying
your child probably should be in an
e-learning situation
or a remote learning situation versus
coming in because it's too dangerous for
them
you think that they may say certain kids
will come come in but will have fewer
people in the classroom
by taking kids with with conditions that
may make them more at risk and they can
do e-learning
i have a i have a feeling that's where
it's headed interesting
interesting all right well listen
yeah well david i was just actually
coming last two callers
my main question was actually um about
what you had said when you were talking
about being black lives made matter
adjacent
i'm jewish too um and terry crews was
trying to get into it with with don
lemon
but nobody's really letting anybody talk
about what
the founders at the movement the actual
doctrine is
so i don't know why they're just not
letting people know and understand
that yeah there is good people in the
movement but i don't think people
understand what
is being dictated from top down or what
the ultimate goals are
yeah and again we you can argue the
top down doesn't matter because it's a
it's sort of a leaderless organization
but the the point the point i've made
before
is there's a lot of individual black
lives matter
groups saying you know that this we've
got to fight against jewish supremacy in
the israeli-palestinian conflict and our
battle
is the same battle that the palestinians
are fighting it's like listen
check out my clips about the
israeli-palestinian conflict you will
find that that i have a
you know measured take on what is going
on but it is not the same battle there's
a lot of anti-semitism within black
lives matter and the women's march which
we talked about previously
and so i'm right there about structural
racism in the united states i'm right
there about
all of these different issues but to say
this is this is the same battle the
palestinians are fighting against
israelis it's like
no it's not and you're going to lose a
lot of people if people are paying
attention you're going to lose a lot of
people with that argument
yeah they just don't understand the
history of the conflict and how it's
been going on for
absolutely way way way too long but i
just want to say thank you for
everything you do
i keep telling everybody to check out
the show and to join like i did
please i mean i'm an out of work
contractor for um
instructional design and education
however i can definitely afford with the
discount to get your show on there keep
keep it going thank you and a great job
and we love watching you every day man
eli i appreciate it um say hi to
everybody
there in the chicago area and hope it
all works out with the school year
yes and you take care stay safe happy
and healthy and keep up the good work of
the show it's amazing
all right thank you very much and an
early shabbat shalom my friend thank you
so much
okay let's go next to our caller from
the 914
area code who's calling today from 914.
hi this is ryan did you say ryan
yeah hi um so mike my question is about
the lincoln project i'm sorry if you've
already covered it on the show and i
just missed it but
uh there's this group the lincoln
project that's putting out ads and i
think they're really
really effective ads i was wondering if
you had any comments on them
yeah so lincoln project is anti-trump
republicans it includes kellyanne
conway's husband george conway i believe
steve schmidt former mccain advisor is
involved
uh rick wilson who's been a guest on
this program long-time republican
strategist and
there's a bunch of others but those are
like the three big ones am i right
uh i actually don't know a lot about the
organization
well in any case they've been producing
anti-trump ads i mean listen
the ads are very good i don't know uh
you know
when i see the ad it reinforces the
beliefs i already have but i don't know
if it's changing any minds so to speak
but
to the extent that they have money and
these are republicans who recognize the
danger of donald trump it's great the
ads are very good and we've reviewed a
couple of them on the program before
uh yeah and i i also wanted to point out
a particular ad that i thought was
it blew my mind because i've never seen
anything like it yeah they have this one
ad
called whispers that's the name of it on
the youtube uh
video and it seems like whispers is
intended
just to be seen by donald trump and it's
just meant to throw him into tilt
um if you haven't seen that ad whispers
is a really crazy ad
i i think that actually you know i
mentioned before i don't know how many
minds are being changed by these ads
i actually think you're on to something
which is
the ads are very well calibrated to
trigger donald trump himself and
he has gone on tweet storms as a result
of
not always the ad itself but the fallout
from these ads
and that i think is actually a really
clever aspect to it because
a lot of the damage that has that trump
has suffered has been self-inflicted
damage like nobody said
he had to fail on coronavirus he could
have taken it seriously it was to some
degree self-inflicted
um not the virus the virus would have
been here either way but trump's
reaction so i think the ads are good in
that
in that way that they trigger trump
yeah yeah it's a i've never seen it
before
uh we've never seen anything like what
we're seeing before uh all right my
friend thank you so much for the call i
appreciate it
we are in uncharted territory i think is
the way i would put it
um thanks to everybody who called in was
just taking a few brief phone calls but
i do want to go to a break because the
news has just
broken about the supreme court decision
on donald trump's taxes and that's what
i'm going to talk about
right after this short break